sure no I put a red tape on the floor I  said I don't want no mad narcissistic  ego on this side okay no my seriously  there's people that have a bad  reputations for obvious reasons because  they they they lost their mind because  of the Hollywood system create monsters  sometimes I don't want to work with them  because it's too tough to make a film  it's too difficult I prefer to work with  um I love  the more I think artists are interesting  the more humble they are very often like  someone like Hugh Jackman Violet Davis  is a super humble actress the one of the  the strongest art uh one of the  strongest artists I ever worked with you  know it's like Roger Dickens is a very  very very humble man you know but at the  same time he's a genius I mean I love  the to be to surround myself by people  that are there because they love Cinema  not because they love themselves you  know it's like two different things